they're not like crushing it like maybe
they make a lot of uh money from brand
nails or something but they're spending
way more than they're making yeah and
they buy these like really flashy things
to like
show that they're well off but they're
really they're really not when you truly
come from poverty like it's not an
experience that you're like oh i want
you to keep experiencing it sounds so
rich like [ __ ] it was [ __ ] hard your
kids are never gonna experience it
because they still have a nice house in
their own room i think one of the
reasons why i want my kids to work a
customer service job also is to teach
them how to treat people oh yeah because
you can tell when someone's never worked
customer service and never gotten
punched in the face before you know
[Music]
and we're back welcome back to big mood
did you miss us we missed you where
needy please tell us you missed us
please
we have today a very special lineup of a
very special guest the one and only miss
stacey diaz alpaca
hello there's alright that was amazing
yes that was amazing
a little accident on there too um but
and we also have um one of our fave i
just grabbed her crotch um gina it's
been a while gina darling the one the
only it's pie she's famous
and we're here with her nope and we're
here with me nikki we're missing two of
our our
you know core
members because uh i replaced them one
had a baby
replacing both of them forget about them
we like it we voted for it we all took a
vote and that's what happened uh tiff's
not here because she had a baby and we
were just saying earlier how rude it is
it's so rude she's known the baby for
like two weeks yeah she's already not
even a week like five days yeah you're
ditching us for that for the babe you
know what right stacey's replacement can
that baby speak no can they know english
yeah
[Music]
and then our other friend jess is uh an
accountant and it's peak tax season
right now that's right we're like a real
accountant yeah yeah she's like a real
account with the cpa license got it and
we're like yeah she's like trying to
tell us about tax stuff and we're like
shut up you're replaced
so that's why we got this crew right now
and it's a party and what we're talking
about today is have you ever heard the
saying more money more problems yeah and
you're like um give me the problem yeah
cause i can't relate i feel that well we
came across an article that is about
wealthy people sharing rich people
problems that they often encounter
and the author of the article says i
can't stop thinking about several of
them
like they like oh well actually these
are kind of bad
i haven't read the article yet because i
want to get our genuine reactions to it
but maybe you can relate to these or
if you've been on the other end maybe
you can empathize a little for the
person that is uh yeah i mean let's talk
about it if you've ever had these rich
people problems
call me yeah
um okay so let's get into this the first
one on the list is never really being
sure whether your partner actually loves
you or only tolerates you because your
money makes their life easier oh damn
that's tough mm-hmm i guess that is a
rich people probably never thought about
that yeah
i'm like he loves me for sure yeah yeah
wow
i guess in a way we can really empathize
or relate because not with money but
it's like business-wise status you know
oh
yeah true like oh
my association with
you the their association with me and
then they can get some followers yeah
exactly i've never dated anybody in the
business and the entertainment business
yeah like danny had no idea who i was
yeah or anything and even when i dated i
never told people what i did for work
and i mean i i'm a i'm a smaller creator
you know so i feel like i didn't have
that issue
huh what does it feel like yeah
well gina can talk about it so i've
actually never dated anyone
in the uh entertainment industry because
i always thought i should keep it
separate so i've always dated like
working professionals or whatever
um
because i thought if i dated someone in
entertainment they have to be way higher
than me
but
otherwise i'll feel like they're kind of
using me yeah
yeah um but i do remember dating one guy
who was a professional but whenever we
went out with his friends he talked like
he was my manager oh in a way and i
didn't like it um
like for instance someone stopped me for
a picture and he looked at his friends
and goes yeah she you know this happens
all the time but you know i get used to
it and whatever and you just have to let
her do her thing oh do you want me to
take a picture yeah this happens all the
time with her she's like oh weird or the
friends will ask us like oh uh do you
have any time for dinner next week could
be like oh she's super busy so i don't
know if like we can fit that into the
schedule but like you know you get to
understand she's super busy and stuff
like that and you know everything that
she does you really have to just take it
and like understand that she i'm just
like
okay i'm gonna ask something and then
you could tell me if i'm stepping out of
bounds but how did it feel regarding
this
with the google docs guy
uh so i remember when i first started
talking to him i was like you know you
don't need to date me or sleep with me
to get whatever you want like in because
you guys started a fake of relationships
yeah i mean it was a joke at first like
and i very much love helping friends out
yeah you're really helpful i think you
really are oh like we had a mutual
friend saint who was just trying to
start off and i was like whatever you
need let me know like i even gave him
computer parts because he wanted to
stream i was like whatever you need let
me know i don't need anything from you
yeah and he asked me he's like well is
there anything i can do for you and i
literally have told him every time till
this day just be my friend
that's all i need yeah he didn't believe
that at first he's like are you sure i'm
like yeah just be my friend and then we
went through the whole drama he realized
at the end that on like he's like i
realize now that when you say just be my
friend you really do mean it
like yeah that's all i really need more
valuable than anything else exactly
yeah
so
it's it's like a it's and then i talked
to my friend charles recently too and
he's like do you ever feel like people
just try to be friends with you because
you know status and stuff
and i said yes he goes jesus that's like
the most heartbreaking thing i've ever
had no that's sad yeah so when i got
involved in youtube it was like not a
thing yet like and anyone that knew
about you the youtuber world it was so
niche that this was back in 2007. okay
so it was like it was very new nobody
was making tons of money on the
influencer world was non-existent
nothing that was
not a thing the only reason i got
involved was because um i wanted footage
from my demo reel because my agents were
like we can't submit you for anything
without a demo reel and like
it costs a lot of money to do them and
like you can only get one if you've been
booking but then you can't book without
one so then it's like you it's like a
catch-22 yeah so i uh got cast in this
um sketch group that did really high
quality sketches and i could use it to
put together a demo reel and that's how
i was introduced into this whole world
where i was like these people have
fans and they have like an audience and
they have they're like these huge
channels i like backed my way into this
like
really big youtube channel that i had no
idea this this world existed so everyone
i was introduced to was through
this sketch group and i didn't know that
they were famous like i didn't know that
they like had this thing that's how i
feel about you guys
all of you yeah because i like i walked
into it and then people were like like
you guys the supporters were like oh my
god you hung out with them i was like
and yeah yeah and
they're here you know and so i feel like
maybe if i would have started as a fan
yeah it would have been it would be very
different right now the world before
yeah but it was literally like yeah yeah
so i didn't put anyone on a pedestal oh
yeah they were like famous but then i
saw
them with other people who were like
clearly clout chasing or like like
getting together with them and they were
they were such vulnerable people because
a lot of youtubers were introverts and
they were kind of nerdy like in their
childhood so yeah they're not used to
getting all this validation or or
attention or fans and so when someone
like
comes at them that way like we talked
about love bombing in another episode
they really believe it they really think
that someone's there for them and it
turns out that they're just there for
the clout the fame and the like whatever
they could
mooch off them and it's really sad yeah
i can't really say that i've had that um
but i did have a boyfriend who felt like
um he needed to bring me down because he
thought
and again this was back when i was not
making money from youtube like it was
not like a profession yet i was still
waitressing but i did have a lot of like
there was a lot of fans of that show who
would stop me
when we were out like if we were in a
restaurant they'd want to take a picture
or whatever and so like he saw that and
he thought like oh i need to tear her
down a notch and it's like i didn't ask
for that like i i'm not you i'm not like
a person that really likes and even if
you're worried who the [ __ ] are you yeah
yeah yeah so he would you know he would
do go out of his way to like try to make
me feel small i hate when people do
because he's like well you're nikki limo
like deal with it and i'm like what like
that's not this makes sense i generally
didn't think i was going to be like i
portecitos the rich people and that one
i'm like oh that's yeah
yeah yeah because you like really have
to keep your friendship so small to know
who's genuine yeah i i met all of my
friends and my fiance literally before i
had any sort of clout that's so good so
i mean i do feel very fortunate because
thankfully like i have no problem being
like i'll pay for you i'll take you yeah
because i they were my friends with dude
they were my friends when i was like
they're [ __ ] poor yeah
those are the people that know you i
feel very very grateful
me and gina both have two high school
best friends that i'm like these are
still my closest friends yeah because
they like know me inside and out rich or
poor for better for worse like i mean
yeah i mean it's not like i'm freaking
rich but for example now my high school
best friend we reconnected recently and
i'm like start a youtube channel i need
to freaking post yeah i want you to make
money i want you to learn the life you
want yeah like come up with me like
whatever little cloud i get i want you
guys to get the same yeah yeah more yeah
i want you to feel good too about what
you have to offer the world yeah yeah
that really sucks i can't imagine like
someone just staying with you for your
money and it's so it's so it's such a
common thing yeah that's such a like a
huge common thing where people just date
someone for their money
and then after you sign those papers or
get pregnant or whatever they're like
all right peace out like there's that
one basketball player that was dating a
girl for a while
and the moment she got pregnant and or
they they got married and the moment she
got pregnant she cut him out completely
and she she she made it it was pretty
clear she made it very clear like yeah i
did it like it was just with him for his
money whatever oh my god yeah and he was
like a young nba player too
yeah it is hard to tell the difference
like if someone's really good at what
they do too
man okay so the second one is if people
know you're rich they expect you to pay
more than what is the
price like when
i once worked at a resort and a service
charge was included with everything so
tips weren't expected but when a known
rich couple arrived the staff bitched
about how they never tipped even though
no one at the resort does
oh like you should give you should be
more generous because you have more
money like it's expected not
and i feel like nobody likes it when
things are expected yeah like if i want
a tip out of the kindness of my heart
that's great
but if you are automatically expecting
like a 50 tip because you know like
that's like yeah
i haven't had this but um
i've had people like once
see this is the other thing when i was
talking about like where people see like
youtube or like they think like oh like
you're famous or like this channel is
doing really well they think you're rich
so at the time i was not rich we were
not making money it i was just a cast
member on a show that was doing well but
they equated it with
being wealthy or something and they
expected me to pay for everything like
pay for lunches pay for dinners and i'm
like yo like i'm not like i'm hurting
like i'm in debt yeah it's not it's not
like that um i guess the only way i can
relate to that is when i my my
ex-boyfriend
uh
in asian culture
men pay
period you know i love it most ethnic
cultures right mexicans yeah
and i remember him saying he was
bitching like
he was the one that's like oh i got this
meal can you get the next one ew
creation yeah taiwanese so it's like
this is so bizarre
that he wanted exactly yeah yeah and i
remember at one point like he kept on it
was like he was keeping tabs he's like
well i paid for this this and this and
this i'm like what the hell i'm saying
he's an accountant exactly and then he's
and then i remember
when he said
well i mean you make more money than me
so you should what i'm just like
yikes
big yikes yeah like big big yikes like
yeah you should be paying for more
because like you make way more money
than me
like
it was weird like it was super strange
and he was like keeping tabs well i
bought this and i paid for this and blah
blah blah
um that's never cute yeah it was just so
unattractive like it's just corny
because even if you like as a successful
woman that makes more than the average
man you still want to feel courted you
still want to feel taken care of like i
said in another episode even if he's
taking you to chili's yeah if that's
what you can afford i feel very grateful
to be here with you you know because i
love you but the intent yeah it's the
intent but for you to be like well take
me to a steakhouse because you make this
amazing yeah exactly like you're
entitled to it yeah yeah that argument
came up because we were flying to
arizona and it was 35 for extra to sit
next to each other because the seats
were all split up and i was like okay
well we have to pay 35 bucks to sit next
to each other he goes well it's only an
hour and a half flight do we have to
like i'd rather not pay 35 bucks i was
like
he was stingy he was cheap and then it's
like i had to explain to him like it's
not the money it's if this plane goes
down and we die i want to be next to you
and then he's like oh okay yeah okay
then let's spend the 35 dollars he's
like you have to understand though like
you make more money than me
first of all you're not poor you're a
lawyer yeah yeah you don't work like a
regular job exactly you can afford it
yeah yeah especially in the same week
you're telling me you want to buy a
rolex oh yeah
so that's okay this is just a side note
but i don't understand there's actually
like this is that happens a lot i've
seen in especially in the influencer
world where
they're not like crushing it like maybe
they make a lot of uh money from brand
deals or something but they're spending
way more than they're making yeah and
they buy these like really flashy things
to like
show that they're well off but they're
really they're really not and then so
that's really it's weird when they're
like come on you make more money than me
and then they're flashing their rolex or
they're driving their tesla or whatever
the hell i'm like it's does it act like
just be consistent yeah okay
you're it's financially immature yeah
yeah yeah
yeah i don't know um
it could also be that like you know like
being a lawyer but then you had to pay
out you have a student loan that's like
twice a double mortgage i don't care how
much like that i have i will never
be like well i put it in someone's face
yeah yeah yeah even as a friend like if
i take you out to dinner i'm never gonna
be like why pay for dinner exactly can
you pay for my movie ticket yeah like if
it doesn't come out of your heart don't
do it at all don't even date me it makes
it so awkward too yeah just being rude
but like and it's like the shamelessness
to be like well i paid for dinner so you
should pay for x y and z like
you yeah it just feels transactional
it's gross yeah whatever your style is
now more than ever is the time to rock
it but maybe you can just use a little
nudge to find some new looks you know
switch it up a little that's where
stitch fix can help you out it's so easy
and fun to get started well first of all
what you're going to want to do is go on
the website and you set up your stitch
fix profile you just answer some
questions about like what do you like to
wear what don't you like to wear how
open are you to try new styles it's
really cool too because they show you
like pictures of the outfits they're
talking about so it's i don't know if
you're a visual person like me it's like
really easy to be like yes or no i hate
it i love it then stitch fixes expert
stylists will go to work and they find
items exclusively for you every piece is
hand-picked for you and it is unique to
your size style and in your budget
making it the best way to discover
clothes that make you look and feel your
best stitchfix will send you five pieces
to try on at home and then what you do
is you try them on you look in the
mirror you go oh and then you keep what
you love and they send back what you
don't and shipping returns and exchanges
are easy and free and there's no
subscription required try it once or set
up automatic deliveries there are no
hidden fees ever you sign up today at
stitchfix.com
mood to get twenty dollars off your
first purchase that's stitchfix.com mood
to get twenty dollars off your first
purchase limited time offer purchased
within two days of sign up attention
everyone are you ready to be blown away
men and women alike asked for it and
they listened our friends at manscape
just relaunched the ultra smooth package
it's back baby your new favorite tool
and compliment to the lawnmower 4.0 to
get that smooth shave finish that you're
looking for this specialized groin
shaving kit is here to help you buff
protect and shave your most sensitive
areas it's time to crop that brush of
yours and get right to the roots with a
discount just for you from manscape get
20 off plus free shipping at
manscape.com with the code mood not only
has manscape brought you the electric
trimmer that you and your men both love
to use but they're now bringing back
your new favorite razor so you can be
set and trimmed front to back this is
the durable yet sensitive razor that's
perfect for him and her i hate having to
shave and getting to those really hard
spots and i always end up missing a spot
and it sucks and razor burn is so gross
so step one grab your handy lawnmower
4.0 and shave to your liking to get the
loose hairs out of the way and then take
out the perfect package for the summer
the manscaped ultra smooth package step
two is a crop exfoliator infused with
ingredients that soothe clear and keep
the skin in and around your groin
feeling refreshed the crop exfoliator
can help reduce the risk of ingrown
hairs in your delicate places step three
is a crop gel see where you're shaving
with a unique clear shaving gel just for
the groin with four essential oils it's
like a small treatment every time you
shave and then step four it's time to
shave the crop shaver was designed for
shaving the groin area with confidence
three precision blades include extra
wide lubricating strips and pivoting
head for the ultimate groin grooming
experience the crop shaver is not your
average razor it's smaller thicker with
a micro comb bar that allows the first
shave possible from any angle the crop
exfoliator and crop gel are both vegan
cruelty free and sulfate free so you
know your goods down there are in good
hands and without compromise it's time
to get up close and personal with the
best tools for the job the ultra smooth
package from manscaped get 20 off plus
free shipping with the code
moodmanscape.com that's 20 off plus free
shipping with the code mood manscape.com
get smooth with the relaunch ultra
smooth package from your friends at
manscape okay feeling like you can't
talk about certain things with people
who don't make as much this person says
i'm not rich but i make more than some
of my friends and there have been times
when i'll confide in them about
something and i get a sarcastic must be
nice response that's jealousy yeah
you don't want friends like that either
but then imagine like okay so obviously
like if there was a girl
for example if there was a girl here who
always grew up with money and her she
was old money and she was to be like oh
my god it's so hard because i have to go
to nyu and i have to leave like
like my friends i'd be like [ __ ] get
over it yeah you [ __ ] you never had to
do
any of the things i had to do you never
had to live in one room with all your
your whole family so get the [ __ ] over
it yeah i do feel bad though because
because she has to go to nyu no no no
but no because they have nothing to
compare to like their pain
is all they know right so like your pain
is always the worst
based off of whatever life you've lived
so like i could say
you know i could be really poor in
america but like i'm better off than
someone that's starving in africa or
something and there's always going to be
someone that's like well you've never
had to sleep in on a dirt floor and it's
like that's true but your pain is still
valid it is so it's like it is when
someone's i know it's hard because like
these are like the one percenters and so
it's really hard to relate to their pain
but i do have to keep in mind that they
don't have anything to compare to and
this is painful for them but for example
like the thing is kylie jenner is never
going to talk to me about how rough she
had it because she couldn't get like a
pink bugatti yeah you know like she's
not going to talk to me about it just
like i'm not going to go talk to
somebody who has lessons
yeah so i mean i'm not saying like this
person's right or wrong like i just
can't imagine
hearing somebody yeah for example i come
from mexico i didn't know english till i
was 13. like to hear somebody say oh my
god like i never amounted to anything
because my parents didn't give me money
to go to college i would be like [ __ ]
i'm on it to something i didn't even
know english yeah 10 years ago or
whenever however long ago you know so it
all depends who you're venting to so
that's tough yeah that is tough i also
in general don't
really like
i don't really have a lot of sympathy
when people um blame
their problems on something that's not
really why their problems happen like oh
i never mounted anything because my
parents didn't give me money to problems
like if you have a if there's a will
there's a way yeah i believe and and so
like things like that is harder for me
to sympathize with than someone being
like
damn i can't pay rent this month because
even though i'm working two jobs like i
can't pay rent this month and it sucks
uh even though like there's people that
can't even can't even have a nice roof
over their head you know like that that
i can empathize with a little bit more
like you're busting your ass still and
you still can't pay around yeah i feel
for you like imagine if for example you
have friends who work like nine to fives
right and you guys do what you do for
work and you're like oh my god like i
was gonna wrap my car in like this two
blue
and but i couldn't because it was seven
thousand dollars i could only for five
thousand and your friend's like [ __ ] i
can't even afford my [ __ ] rent yeah
yeah like
but please it's the uh
yeah they're so rare from
reality they're not self-aware like i
think i saw a video of one of the hadid
sisters saying like yeah when i was
growing up i wasn't given everything i
had to struggle too like i didn't get my
first pair of red bottoms until i
graduated high school oh my gosh and
people were like oh geez oh no are you
[ __ ] kidding me you're trying to be
relatable yeah oh jesus christ that's so
sad and it's a different world you can't
relate
it's they were never
they never went through the struggle so
i can't really be like you're [ __ ]
dumb yeah but it's like it's if they if
they've never experienced that you can't
expect them to know what to say and
stuff but
uh it's different like if you came from
nothing and became rich and you're still
talking like that you're a piece of [ __ ]
like yeah
yeah you should know yeah i had this
friend well she wasn't like a really
good friend but she was she was an
acquaintance it was a colleague and i
always like thought we were kind of on
the same page she would talk about how
man she could buy more clothes she's
broke and i'm like me too like i'm
shopping from the discount rack at this
store but they had some sales i would
share like deals with her that i found
and i thought we were kind of like on
the same page until
she got like um her car got like a
little bit hit like like a fender bender
but it was like there was like not even
a dent like it was just like a like
barely even a scratch and her parents
just bought her a new car
and
and then i found out that she's [ __ ]
lost
but she's not loaded her parents are
loaded and she always felt like she
needed to make her own money but like
she didn't even though she was
technically broke she never had to worry
about like if i can't make my rent this
month i'm going to be on the street like
that's never going to happen for her
what is it a safety net yeah yeah like
it's hard to relate
to somebody like when you come from like
literal like we literally gonna eat
hard-boiled eggs and tuna all week yeah
that's all we're gonna eat because
there's nothing to eat yeah you ca like
it's really hard when i met steve i was
like i had to pick between me eating or
my cat's eating it's always going to be
my cats so my 89 cents went to my cats
um and i would steal he like asked me
why i was taking all the crafty and
putting in my purse and i like was so
embarrassed that i got caught but like i
i just was used to that because i don't
know when i'm gonna see my next meal
like that's
that's gonna have to last me through the
week yeah so our first date he um at the
end of the date he slipped he's like oh
you dropped this and you put something
in my purse and he's like don't look at
it now and then i went upstairs and i
opened it and it was a ralph's gift
certificate he got me 50 of groceries
and he's like to the girl who who
doesn't you have to steal from crafty
anymore
that's cute and i was like i'm gonna
marry him yeah i would have
promoted it
he knew he remembered that was like from
months earlier when we weren't even he
wasn't we weren't in a relate we weren't
dating nothing was happening and like i
just couldn't believe he remembered that
and i had like negative money in my
account at the same time
so i was like oh my god my cats and i
can both eat yeah that's so sweet yeah
we love a provider man yeah if i ever
heard something like that like a rich
person saying things like oh god i can't
afford to feel my private jet this week
and it's just i won't say anything but
i'm just gonna be like
bro okay yeah yeah that's wild yeah okay
this one is my rich friend has no kids
so he's trying to figure out how to
spend all his money before he dies so it
doesn't go to some cousins he doesn't
like if i just mention something like
he'll buy it for me immediately it's
ridiculous
does he need more friends i don't know
if this is a problem that's nice how do
i how do i spell my money before i die i
mean i think
if you don't like the person
i um
there was a case on tv that came out
that this lady left all her money to
her dog and basically she hired somebody
to take care of her dog because she was
gonna die the dog was probably like two
or three years old yeah and so she
basically hired the dog that's
responsible yeah but she didn't want to
like she want to give her money to like
her family members because she didn't
have kids or stuff like that yeah and so
she literally like kept the house and
like
paid people like a company to take care
of her dog for as long as the dog lived
because i was gonna live another 15
years
and i was like damn that's why other
people have money like that yeah yeah
that's the plot of aristocrats but the
person that i don't want to spoil
aristocats for you but um
it starts it's the beginning of the
movie uh the the
rich lady
wills her money to the butler but to
take care of the cat so the cats own the
money and then the butler is trying to
figure out how to get all the money he
puts the cats on the streets then like
there are these rich cats that don't
know how to be on the streets and they
re they meet like a street cat it's a
cute movie yeah what like why don't you
just hey when i die just donate all of
it to this charity of my choice that's
true like live lavish while you're
living and then just donate the rest
yeah let's start a fund like start uh
start a charity
that's wild though like i can't even
imagine look at us finding solutions
hire us
are you rich you have problems we'll
solve it
just give us your money yeah this gives
you money we'll figure it out we'll
figure it out we'll figure it out okay
as a woman it can make it hard to
navigate relationships because a lot of
men still identify with the breadwinner
role
we were talking about this yeah
people they can get kind of competitive
they can
yeah feel like one guy i knew we were
talking we were playing this game called
we're not really strangers
and the question was uh what do you make
a year oh hell no and i was like i don't
want to answer that i'd rather just take
my shot yeah and then it was in a group
of friends like close friends i was like
i don't want to answer that and they
were like come on gina whatever i'm like
i never answered that question but then
that night for once i actually did and
the guy that i was seeing i i noticed a
very significant change in personality
no girl
i play the fifth lie too your teeth are
blue i don't care
yeah because like i don't know how much
money jana makes yeah like if i google
her i'll probably say like a million
dollars but i don't need to know because
and even in a relationship like that
like unless they're your husband again
yeah for what because then you can
we talked about in another episode but
you can run into the homosexuals that
are like i love you hobo
no not homo hobo homosexuals that are
like i want to date you and you're my
sugar mama and like buy me this and buy
me that and you know you just put the
target on your back in general yeah
because like even in the in the like
public eye
i've had people
commenting like dude nikki and steve
were so broke because blah blah blah
like they they make this much a year i
googled it and then and then which isn't
true and then i also have people that
are like dude they're so rich i'm not
doing anything with it i googled them
they make their fi they have five
million dollars net worth i'm like
that's not true either but like the fact
that it even matters like in your mind
like that equates to something that i
should be doing or should not be doing
because i have x amount of money is like
i don't want to feel beholden to that
like
you shouldn't no one should have a say
in that besides me and maybe my partner
if we're married but um yeah so i can't
even imagine like dating
them being like oh well it puts a new
expectation on you like you should be
doing this or i should be doing this and
i genuinely think like a man who's truly
like loves you and wants to provide for
you you're like that's nice but i still
want to take care of you exactly you
know like i still want to make you feel
taken care of protected yes like i want
to take you out you know you shouldn't
change anything yeah and it's not like
you're i've never gotten the vibe from
you that you're like snobbish about
nobody that you're like oh my god i have
those
in fact we make fun of this [ __ ]
because we're like dude you have money
get get get a house get a get us
something do something with it and she's
like she's got a plan
yeah she has stuff to do with it and
that's her business but we like we'll
still make fun of her until this day
i've been i mean i figured you had
influencer money because i mean this is
the work we do but i never
like this conversation is the first time
that i'm like oh yeah gina is probably
rich as [ __ ] but i never
i had never thought about it like that
you know i was just like oh yeah we all
make around the same i don't know how
much that is but we all make around the
same to be honest it's smart because you
should be living under your means and
then investing that [ __ ] and like
creating
assets that provide uh you know yeah
cash flow in your dating world don't
talk about it yeah [ __ ] that question
yeah as far as i'm concerned no matter
who asks i will tell them i'm [ __ ]
poor yeah you know i still i still drive
a [ __ ] haunted city
yeah i love my honda civic too
dude i was so happy you drive honda
civic too because i had to borrow your
car last time and i was like how to
drive this except yours like talks
japanese to me so
that's right how cute i was like okay
i'm in an anime
yeah it's
it's just better you're better off to
just not know that question yeah do not
know the answer
because it shouldn't change anything i
mean eventually you're gonna get married
and you're gonna have your partner and
then they'll know you know but at that
point i feel like you'll know them
enough to share that information and on
the other hand too like if you're going
to get married to someone you guys
better know each other's debts yeah yeah
because you're marrying it and if you're
divorced you're taking half of it oh
yeah and you just have to be okay with
like if one of us makes a financial
choice like we're in it together like we
need to make all the financial choices
together from here on out and if
something happens there can't be blame
on like the end result yeah that's tough
okay
this one is there's definitely a problem
of people taking advantage of being your
friend for privilege over your stuff oh
yeah
like um
my ex used to throw in my face all the
time
um well i do your legal work for you and
i pay for most meals and i was like okay
and
and so like that was always the default
whenever we argued but i don't keep tabs
because i think that's corny i'm never
gonna throw anything in your face right
yeah uh but towards the end of the
relationship
uh when i found out he cheated he's like
yeah well find someone else that does
your legal work
a lawyer yeah like
most people do yeah i i can yeah because
we'll find someone to do for free like i
don't need to because i could pay people
i can't afford
a lawyer not a dime a dozen right you're
like i drive a honda civic i can afford
a lawyer yeah right saving money exactly
um and then it finally came down to i
was so pissed
that he would throw that in my face
again um so i told him i was like cool
so you listed two things you did for me
right
find someone else that can get you into
every club for free never have to pay
for a drink get all the things that you
want influence your stuff for free every
movie premiere you wanted to go to
everything like all this [ __ ] that you
never had to pay for and that's his
thing too like he likes going out he
loves that yeah he loves the image
or like if i if there's something that
he wants from a brand i'll reach out to
them you know like
and i just get him everything and find
someone who buys cleaning supplies to
clean a [ __ ] apartment she doesn't
even live in you know
and then also
find someone else on tv yeah go ahead go
ahead find it yeah and like i don't ever
wanted to get down to that but then what
he said to me was yeah well none of
those things came out of your pocket so
it doesn't count
these are
privileges and and perks of my career
that i've worked 12 years for yeah that
i'm sharing with you he's going to say
his legal work that he did which is his
career he wanted to charge me towards
like later on
all the stuff i did for him and he had a
business that i promoted to i did for
free
you know and but he's like well you know
it's kind of unfair because like i need
to start charging maybe just a small
rate and then but it's like it comes
down to yeah i didn't have to pay for
most of these things or whatever but i
could be using it for myself yeah my
loved ones for whatever but you're just
sitting there saying well it didn't come
from your pocket so it doesn't matter
okay that one when you brought up uh
promoting that's when i can relate to
where like people don't want to use my
stuff but like i'd always have like
random like people that weren't even my
friend friends asking me to promote
their new song or their new [ __ ] or
whatever and like they come out of the
woodwork to like ask you to promote [ __ ]
and i love promoting my friends i'll i
was wearing gina's merch earlier because
yeah i [ __ ] love like if someone has
something i'll wear i love stacy's
jewelry like if someone has something
they're selling they're my friend i'll
[ __ ] buy it i don't need them to give
it to me for free or anything i'm just
like go buy my friends [ __ ] go watch my
friend's show i just love that my
friends are [ __ ] doing things but
when you like haven't shown any
friendship to me like i met you and we
hung out once or whatever and then you
come out of the woodwork and ask me to
promote your [ __ ] it's like
i feel weird man because like you know
companies pay us to promote it and
that's not a secret companies pay us a
lot of money to promote their brand
which is cool that's how we make our
money but like
getting it for free is like it is a
friendship thing that i think people
don't realize how like that is part of
our job like that is
how we make money like on this show we
have sponsors we talk about the sponsors
and i genuinely love our sponsors i
genuinely use their stuff but they're
paying us to tell you about it too and
so when we talk about summoner go promo
go what listen my friend steph it's like
it's a genu it should be a genuine thing
not because i feel like guilted cause
you knew me and we hung out once and you
complimented my hair and so now i should
like
examine your thing but people do feel
entitled to it and people do feel like
come on like what's the big deal like
it's not that hard for you like you can
just make one post yeah just like make
one post like i haven't posted in like
three days one post is like a third of
my feed for the month like
yeah um what is it i
like it when it's our genuine friends we
promote it without even having to ask to
yeah i just do it right sometimes yeah
but
like you too like people just come out
of the woodworks like an ex-boyfriend
came out
of nowhere he's like hey cookie um now
that you're a big deal do you mind
promoting my blah blah blah and i was
like
no and he tried again two years later
i'm like bro get the [ __ ] away from me
yeah
it's it just feels gross and it starts
from the very beginning too like when i
started modeling when i was
17 going to senior year and i started
and then this girl just randomly
messaged me out of nowhere like hey can
you help me with my modeling career can
you post my picture or like whatever
like can you get me a photographer and i
messaged her back straight up i'm like
you and i haven't even spoke yeah this
whole entire [ __ ] year and you don't
even say hello how are you first it's
hey can you give me this that that
exactly is it yeah it's like there's not
even a trying to be a friend first it's
just like hey you can do this and it's
easy for you so can you do it for me you
know like why won't you do it for me why
wouldn't you yeah it's easy for you and
i have friends now where i'm like even
if i don't talk to you enough a lot i
know like i know our friendship and they
know my friendship or with them or our
friendship where it's like i
on the other hand like i don't have to
go through the nice cities of like hey
how are you yeah what's going on it's
more like dude just ask me what you want
yeah you know exactly that's exactly
because it was all right it was already
earned yeah like my girlfriend anna that
my best friend from high school lives
two miles away from me she doesn't have
to like i've seen like once a month
right not even that maybe we text each
other once a month exactly but then if
she were like hey can you promote this
for me but like yeah sure like i don't
want you to go through those niceties
but if you're someone that i haven't
spoken to for years and you're just like
faking a conversation just get something
out of me like dude that's gross or like
sometimes it doesn't come till the end
where they're like it seems like they're
just reaching out hey i was just
thinking about you blah blah blah how's
this how's that oh you guys just bought
a house how is vegas and then the varian
is like so yeah i just started this new
business and i was like i was wondering
if you could just like give me a shout
out or like oh man you were just faking
that whole conversation i thought you
were like genuinely reaching out that
stupid ugly
yeah it does it doesn't feel good so i
could
relate to that part of this um okay the
next one
is
i have a very wealthy friend and seeing
firsthand how all your poorer relatives
move closer to you and start asking you
for things and money blew my mind
everyone from siblings down to the
ex-boyfriend of a second cousin will
straight up demand he buy them a
vacation home when he inevitably says no
they go scorched earth policy on social
media and talk about how selfish he is
and how he disowns his family for money
then a month later they're back begging
on his doorstep it's exhausting and i'm
just watching from the outside oh my
gosh that's insane yeah that's crazy
so i can't relate to that but eminem
sings about it all the time
so i feel like i relate also you have so
much family i remember um
what i struggled with before when i was
dirt poor was when i would date people
who made more money than me
and their first gifts for me are like
extravagant this and that and then
they're like but you know you don't have
to get anything equal to it which i
understand they're being very genuine
but yeah yeah me i'm like oh i don't
know how to compensate for this yeah
exactly so
that's a
i just thought about that one i just
can't imagine ever like going up like i
have relatives i have an uncle who's
like very well off and he wasn't always
well off but like his business took off
and so now he's like rich or his family
and so i can't imagine ever being like
oh
can i have money for this yeah we're
gonna have money for that like if they
offer a gift
wonderful but like i have never been
like oh uncle because i know you have
money can you give me money for this or
that yeah
it's crazy
oh
i had a relative
like that once yeah because i went to go
visit their family and their mom is a
single mother she lost her husband
single mother raising three boys wow um
living on a hair stylist income okay and
so i saw and i was like okay so i'm just
gonna
amazon order a bunch of things that she
needs for the house you know like their
house got broken into twice
because they don't live in the best
neighborhood so i got cameras installed
you know and like stuff to just make her
life easier and then
um you know i'm i haven't seen her kids
in a while you know they're adults now
and you know i'm catching up with every
uh every every one of her kids and then
a week later one of her kids messages me
saying hey um are you free to talk i
need help like i'm like i need someone
to talk to i'm like oh yeah sure what's
going on
and
he was telling me like yeah i ran this
red light or something whatever and i
need five hundred dollars and i was like
oh no
oh this is not going to start like this
and then so i was like
i don't want that kind of relationship
because once it starts it doesn't stop
and it gets weird
so i i just made up something like sorry
i just paid like 50 000 down payment for
something so i can't like i'm not
starting this relationship with you
because you are fully capable you know
and the week before he had just told me
yeah you know i'm starting to date this
girl now but it's kind of a struggle
because she loves like designer stuff so
i'm trying to provide that for her
there it is yeah and i was like yeah
okay no no we're not doing this that
only happened to with a family member um
who was an addict uh in my family
and for some reason they kept getting
parking tickets and they couldn't ask
anyone else for help except for me
and i the first time i gave the money
and they're like i swear i'll pay you
back my i'm getting money this this week
from my job
i just need it like i just don't want my
parents to know blah blah blah and then
i never got it and then um i didn't want
to bring it up it was 80 bucks or
whatever and then like the next month
same thing i was like i got another
parking ticket and like i really just
like there's this parking's crazy out
here i'm like you need to learn how to
park better dude like i can't just keep
giving you money for parking tickets you
didn't pay me back the last time yeah
and and i know that they had a problem
but they wouldn't they would lie like
you know because they do that so that's
the only other that's the only time
where i've dealt with that kind of thing
where it's like man
you want to be nice and
you know that they are hurting for money
but also they have
other things that they're spending it on
yeah
i feel like it also uh it works with
them
praise too because i remember when i
first was releasing my first clothing
collection
uh one of my family members was like one
of my close close family members too i
was telling them like i'm so excited
about this i hope it goes well they're
like okay cool and then once it like
sold out like immediately
all of a sudden they hit me up they're
like oh i'm so proud of you and posting
on facebook i'm so proud of them and i'm
just like dude you suck like do you need
more like how about i invest in it for
you and i'm like no i'm good yeah it's
too late yeah yeah it's weird support
when we need this apart you know like
but before it's a thing when you start
on your health journey it's really easy
to be overwhelmed by all the information
the wellness industry throws at you but
noom believes the only place that you
really need to start is with your mind
yeah your mental
everyone listen up people in the back a
couple things i like about new more than
any other program that i've tried is one
it really focuses on a behavioral
approach so like changing your mental to
change your habits which your habits
will in turn change your lifestyle which
will in turn change you to be the person
that you want to be more than the person
that you are now maybe that you're not
satisfied with so one thing that i
realize that i do is i stress eat all
the time like i anxiety eat i if i have
boredom or anxiety or stress i am
grabbing snacks and i don't even know
i'm doing it so i was keeping a food
journal
like as suggested by them and then also
just like being really cognizant of when
i'm reaching for snacks and it really
helped a lot because instead of reaching
for snacks now i just like do some
meditation take a couple deep breaths
realize i'm not actually hungry i also
do the same thing in social situations
because of anxiety i felt like i always
had to have a drink in my hand or food
in my hand i always had to like be
doing something consumption wise with
being in social situations and it's not
it's not healthy okay and then the other
thing i really like about nume is that
it fits into my schedule it's like
10 minutes a day who doesn't have 10
minutes a day you just like you live
your life on your terms you know what
i'm saying there's no like oh no i gotta
go block out two hours to get this
workout in you know it's just like
i'm getting exercise i'm changing my
habits i'm feeling good about myself so
start building better habits for
healthier long-term results sign up for
your trial today at noomnoom.com
big mood that's noom noom dot com slash
big mood to sign up for your trial today
we deserve to know what we're putting in
our bodies and why especially when it
comes to something that we take every
single day i'm talking about vitamins
they're always telling you you gotta
take your vitamins but they don't tell
you the difference in quality and
believe me there's a huge difference so
i started taking ritual vitamins in 2017
oh my god it's been five years wow
also i've been taking the prenatal one
since 2019
and i have noticed a drastic difference
i know that's really anecdotal and
you're right but i took blood tests
before i started taking ritual and i was
super super low on vitamin d and my
doctor was very concerned she was even
like you gotta double up on that d and i
was like oh no and i was really
stressing and then i took blood tests
two years after i started taking ritual
and it was a totally normal vitamin d
score so i know it's really anecdotal
but um gaps in the diet shouldn't be
ignored over 97 of women aged 19 through
50 are not getting enough vitamin d in
their diet and 95 are not getting the
recommended daily intake of key omega-3s
did you know that rituals essential for
women 18 plus multivitamin was
formulated by exhaustive research to
help fill those nutrient gaps in the
diets of women 18 and over it's
formulated with nutrients to help
support brain health bone health blood
health and provide antioxidant support
that's a lot of health but ritual didn't
stop there no they invested in a gold
standard university-led clinical trial
to prove the impact of essential for
women 18 plus multivitamin and the
results uh yeah essential for women 18
plus was shown to increase vitamin d
levels by 43
and omega-3 dha levels by 41
in 12 weeks that's only three months it
was published in the frontiers in
nutrition and ritual is committed to
third-party testing from usp and the
non-gmo project it's traceable and vegan
friendly ingredients and always clear
communication no shady stuff and right
now ritual is offering our listeners 10
off during your first three months visit
ritual.com big mood and turn healthy
habits into a ritual that's 10 off
ritual.com big mood dude okay so
figuring out how to give your kids
everything they want without turning
them into spoiled brats who are messed
up for life that one must be hard
because i told steve i was like if we're
ever like multi multi millionaires we
have to make our kids think we're poor
yeah like somehow we're gonna rent like
a separate place and like only live
there until they're 18.
because like i don't know how to
you need to have the kids learn the
value of a dollar yeah and i don't know
how a rich family would do that um i
know with asian families when they have
a lot of money a lot of them are like
we just want our kids to focus on
studies so we'll take care of everything
while they're going to school and that's
where the hard work comes in yeah they
never had to have a day job
that's or like they never had to work in
customer service and it's like you need
to have your kids yeah earn their money
everyone should have to work in customer
service a service job for at least two
so look i'm gonna hit you guys from the
other side okay not like i grew up with
money i don't have all the money in the
world like my kids are still gonna have
to learn values because we're not rich
but to me it's like if and when we make
it to a point where we have so much
money i don't want them to go through
what i went through because it was
[ __ ] hard
and
the trauma i created to
like there's times where i wouldn't even
finish
food on the pantry because i'm like i
don't know who's coming in next and i
don't want them to like even though we
can easily go get food now but i don't
want you to be like oh it's empty you
know like i still constantly have to
have it stocked up so that denny now
doesn't feel like it's empty right when
he has never thought about that you know
so
i'm all about yeah make them get like
jobs but i feel like maybe we didn't
grow up like that but rich people their
kids also work they're just working as
interns for like in law firms or interns
for ceos you know when they're 17 18
years old so they're learning how to be
ceos right as opposed to people like us
who grew up working in supermarkets who
grew up working in
uh i don't know restaurants and things
like that we learn how to be employees
that's true
that's very true if it was like that
where they're actually working and
they're not just like all right we'll
give you a job and like it's like kind
of a what's it called the um
the when you get in a job because
you nepotism it's not just nepotism like
you automatically get to be manager
because your dad owns the company or
whatever like if it's like they're
sincerely starting from the bottom
working their way up learning how to
manage people from like the bottom up
and they're learning things then i'm
okay with them not having to have worked
at a supermarket first or whatever but
if it's just like they expect to be
handed money because i spoiled the [ __ ]
out of them when they were eight years
old they like they just grew up always
getting handed money all the time they'd
never had to do chores never had to do
anything to like
see where how money is earned then i
think that's really hard and that's a
parent thing yeah parenting thing not
like a kid thing right so
you are responsible for not just giving
them money right so like even if you're
rich or you're middle class
you
teach them the value of the dollar by
making them do things right or teaching
them how to invest and absolutely love
for my parents to know how to invest so
i wouldn't have had to figure it out
that's so true right so like instead of
teaching me okay do this chore you're
gonna get five dollars it's like okay do
you want you want me to keep one of your
dollars and then if i keep it next week
you'll get five for that one dollar yeah
you know so like just things like that
that our parents grew up in survival
mode and they didn't have access to but
if i'm rich i don't want my kids to have
to struggle so they know because it
would be fake yeah you know it's not
true it's not real i'm not gonna be like
well let's go to your auntie's house
with this and have money so you see how
lucky you are yeah because then you
create like rude ass kids yeah you'll
create a disparity between us and them
or yeah like oh hey cousin you're poor
it's always it always should be that way
of like you trying to do like just one
step better than what you had to go
through growing up but i am really
thankful
so we grew up really poor but my parents
grew up even poorer so my dad came from
immigrants my mom came from basically
immigrants to like her grandparents and
they were both in poverty like growing
up when i was born i lived in my
grandma's garage my parents were not
even
they barely even started college so like
my mom had to drop out to raise me but i
my dad decided to finish and he gave up
his dream of being baseball player to
become an accountant and my mom was
working as a teller at a bank and so
they
started at entry-level jobs but they
were he is now a cpa and she became the
vice president of a bank so they were in
finances and growing up even though we
were poor they were learning and they
were teaching as they were learning so
my dad and i'll never forget he taught
me how to stay out of debt how to build
a credit score how to um
take advantage of interest how interest
works so what he would do is like if he
needed to borrow cash we had our
allowance money and i had my piggy bank
and he's like i need to borrow five
dollars when i give it back to you i'm
going to give you 5.25 and that's how
interest works when you borrow something
you have to pay interest when you
someone's borrowing from you they have
to give you interest and he taught me
how like investing works because of that
but he didn't go the full
he didn't go the full like stocks and
everything but just that little bit when
i was like eight to ten years old it
stuck with me because i always if i
borrowed money from a friend i would
give them back if i borrowed 20 bucks i
give you back 25. if i you know if
someone
if i'm giving my money to something i
kind of expected interest to be made
um so yeah i i do think that those
little things that i'm i want to teach
my kids how to invest
i feel like i'm at the place where your
parents were like i feel like me and my
relationship i'm there and we will teach
your kids how you were taught you know
but it's like when you truly come from
poverty like it's not an experience that
you're like oh i want you to experience
it sounds so rich like [ __ ] it was
[ __ ] hard your kids are never gonna
experience it because they still have a
nice house in their own room and you
don't want them to yeah yeah
it's not an exp it's not disneyland like
it's yeah like i want my kids to go hang
out with poor kids so they see and
that's that's how my parents were
they're like they're exactly like that
where they're like i never want my kids
to go through what's [ __ ] hard
to get a house where we could have our
own rooms started in my grandma's garage
and then now we have our own rooms and a
house yeah amazing and i will forever
like yeah i'm grateful for them spoiled
no but i will say that um
my brother and i both raised by the same
parents i'm older he's five years
younger than me um i
had a scholarship to college i like was
really good with grades blah blah blah
blah and i decided that that wasn't my
path i'm gonna drop out and go
um pursue acting and i'm gonna pursue it
just like i would college because i see
college as an investment for your career
i'm gonna invest in something for my
career by going this other route they
didn't see it that way they saw college
as the end-all be-all like you have to
go to college in order to get a good job
because that's how they got their good
job that's how exactly and that's how
they got out of poverty and so they were
scared for me so as tough love they're
like if you want if you go to college
we'll pay for everything if you don't go
to college you have to pay for
everything yourself and i was like okay
that's fine i'm gonna pay for everything
i got three jobs i worked my [ __ ] ass
off i was like you know
never i'd never had money but i was so
focused on making that happen my brother
decided i'll take the free ride i'll go
to college he never got good grades he
got straight c's but they were gonna pay
for
so okay i'm gonna go to college i don't
have to work a job all my food's paid
for there's no
consequence other than like and there's
and like he only they made it so easy
because they just wanted him to focus
focus on school but after the school
work's done he's bored what is he gonna
do so he got into trouble and he would
drink and he would like he just
he didn't do what took him seven years
to get through college and then he
didn't use his degree for anything and
so
that was a lot of money those seven
years and it wasn't being used for
anything because they didn't force him
to
learn time management or working or
whatever so they can see the difference
in the balance and it's like i
i don't blame them at all because how
could you even know yeah but me saying
it i'm like damn i don't want to cuddle
my kids to the point where they can just
be lazy and [ __ ] off and think that
everything's paid for now he doesn't
know how to handle himself he does now
he's doing well now he's married he has
a kid he has a job but it took him a
while to get there he's 30 now and so
like i i saw the struggle of not having
trained his brain to like be responsible
have a consequence if you can't make
rent at the end of the month like
there's like there's debt there's things
that you have to go through your credit
score can get [ __ ] up like he never
had to learn any of that firsthand he
had to learn it
way later in life yeah so i'm like okay
there's got to be a middle ground it's a
tough i think one of the reasons why i
want my kids to work a customer service
job also is to teach them how to treat
people oh yeah you can tell when
someone's never worked customer service
and never gotten punched in the face
before you know so it's also like it's
like a responsibility it's like
character development you know you can
put your kid in sports for that too you
know like you'll learn a lot in sports
so i learned all of that in sports and
work in a [ __ ] job but yeah but i
mean like to me the way i see that it's
like i want my kid in sports ever since
they're little because that's where
they're going to learn time management
reliability that's where the discipline
discipline yeah so
it's just
when
and i don't know how to say this without
sounding weird but when people who have
money say i want my kid to experience
poverty no no no no yeah yeah
like it comes off
the rude you know because i was like
[ __ ] it wasn't fun like you don't want
your kids to really experience it so
um
yeah customer service obviously is not
poverty that's like a job anybody can
have it's just
i when i hear that there's kids who
um inherit their parents like um finance
team right so like let's say
the parents always had to find like
three accountants and like a person
telling them what to spend money on and
then the kid grew up watching that
the kid who grew up watching that and
giving those benefits and the kid who
grew up in mcdonald's and worked himself
up to be a manager yeah they might have
the same work ethic but once they were
going to get the opportunities that the
other one got right because they like
this one learned responsibility from
watching his dad be like a good worker
and like a good ceo or whatever and this
one had to learn being the manager of a
mcdonald's
great jobs
but i mean one's never going to amount
to the other one and then it just sounds
weird when you're like well i want
experience yeah i think the customer
service thing is definitely what she was
saying we're like i just want them to
know what it feels like to
serve or like to to be in that realm
where you have to
deal with people in a cordial way in a
way that like
um
yeah you're not always going to get what
you want or what you want to do or what
on your time
i think people that don't wear customer
service and then they come into a
restaurant like oh the waitress is just
like what what do you mean i can't get
saturdays there's tables open like you
you don't know how a restaurant works
then exactly like you can't be like so
entitled to everything without knowing
what it's like on that other side but if
that's what you were always taught
because your family always taught you
that then
yeah you're gonna think that that you
should be sat right away that you should
have like your refills done exactly on
time when you want to do it and this is
a bad waitress and she doesn't deserve a
tip now because she didn't get
everything you wanted the way you wanted
it and
yeah i think there's like i don't know
what that fine line is i definitely
don't want my kids to feel like they're
they don't know when their next meal is
yeah but i do want them to feel like
there's some sort of consequences
for the for their actions if they decide
to [ __ ] off rather than to yeah put
their responsibilities and that's what
more than just money yeah you don't you
don't that's your parents job to teach
you that right because then there's poor
kids that treat service workers like
crap because when they finally get a
hundred dollars they're like i have a
hundred dollars i should be able to do
whatever i want in this restaurant
that's so true so it's not a money thing
it's an entitlement yes thing you know
all right well that is our episode today
let us know in the comments did you drop
rich did you have rich people problems
or did you grow up poor and now you came
into money and you have a whole new set
of problems you didn't know existed or
are you having you're like i'm poor i
can't relate to any of this [ __ ] but all
of you people i'm out
let us know your thoughts we'd love to
hear it also follow stacy everywhere
she's awesome she has so much good life
advice to give you on almost every
platform on youtube on tick tock
instagram wherever you wanna follow her
plus she's planning a wedding so just
like get all the tea on that too
um let us know
follow us i don't i don't know what i'm
saying i'm ending the show get deal with
it
we love you
[Music]
you